Ciao zia bene e tu? bene bene bene
Dai allora ci vediamo il 24 sera
no ma infatti anch'io ho detto meno male che non facciamo sia 24 che 25 perché un cenone basta e avanza poi bisogna smaltire
dai va bene ciao ciao ciao zia
Salve signora si tutto bene grazie
no il 24 sono con la mia famiglia mi disp
però posso passare dopo cena!
Aspetta aspetta mia nipote Alice
Ciao Alice come stai?
bene bene tu? Si ma ci vediamo si si
hai una sorella?
Ciao Betta Eli scusami scusami Eli si tutto si ciao un bacino ciao ciao
Film di Natale un altro film di Natale
Niente allucinante uno sotto natale accende la tv e vede solo film di natale
puntualmente coppie che si innamorano colpi di fulmine limone duri sotto il vischio e basta un po di pace per noi single
amore che film guardiamo stasera?
allora io ho preparato una piccola lista così capiamo quelli che dobbiamo ancora vedere un principe per natale visto un amore sotto l'albero visto 12
volte natale visto l'amore a natale visto matrimonio di neve visto ma amore ma li abbiamo visti tutti
e qual é quello piú dolcino romantichino ino ino ino?
e forse l'amore a natale
l'amore a natale
lo riguardiamo?
siiii
Grazie zia ma non dovevi ma che carina
no vabbè le scarpe che volevo ma te l'ha detto mamma per forza ma grazie
adesso ti do il mio eh aspetta
amore ecco il mio regalo di natale per te ma grazie
ma è vuoto sì perché dentro c'è tutto l'amore che io provo per te
non é il regalo più bello che potessi fare hai proprio lo spirito del natale
ti è piaciuto adesso dammi il mio regalo grazie
Delle scarpe da ginnastica???
hai detto che a gennaio vuoi iscriverti in palestra
io tutti I giorni della mia vita mi guardo allo specchio mi vedo grassa e tu cosa fai? mi regali
per natale delle scarpe da ginnastica perché vuoi che vada in palestra e dimagrisca
non me l'aspettavo da te mi hai deluso mi hai veramente molto deluso
hai presente la canzone di mariah carey all I want for christmas?
esatto quello che voglio per natale sei sempre tu sei sempre stata tu negli ultimi quattro anni
sei stato il mio regalo più bello la luce dei miei occhi la cioccolata calda in una notte fredda
la crema al mascarpone su una fetta di panettone
amore grazie ti amo tantissimo per me é lo stesso ti amo più del pan di zenzero lo sai che lo adoro
hai presente la canzone di mariah carey? all i want for christmas?
tutto quello che voglio per natale amore mio
sei proprio tu
sì perché sono quattro anni che io vado a dormire sognandoti e mi sveglio al mattino pensandoti
sono quattro anni che tu sei la mia crush
e sono quattro anni che sono single perché tu
non ti accorgerai mai di me probabilmente non sai neanche della mia esistenza ma non importa
non importa perché io ti amo ti amerò per sempre
Amore mio sai cosa facciamo adesso?
ti scelgo un bel vestitino per natale
allora vediamo
preferisci l'elfo di babbo natale che é super cure o il biscotto di pan di zenzero?
Oddio per carità questi sono i maglioni da uomo cioè un conto sono gli animali ma io quelli che vanno
in giro col maglione natalizio e magari se ne mettono uno il 24 e uno il 25 diverso perché pensano di colpire ma che tristezza
ma che pochezza
amore
guarda che cosa ho preso allora i maglioncini a tema natalizio questo qua lo puoi mettere iI 24 sera
e questo che è un po più così trap per il 25 così le tue cuginette sono contente fate i tiktok con sferaebbasta
e poi questo questo qui chi lo mettte?
lo diamo alla zia ma no le stará piccolo lo diamo ad alice no é troppo grande
lo metto io amore cosí siamo coordinati
ma che bello
e poi non è finita qui perché poi c'é anche il cappello di babbo natale ma io avevo pensato se tu metti questo qui
e arrivi a casa dalle tue cuginette
penseranno che tu sia babbo natale
pre per ma
Bellissimo sei proprio babbo natale
Allora dal 23 al 7
V A C A N Z A non ne voglio sapere di nessuno unico appuntamento importante 24 sera cena di natale
dal 25 però che sono libera a devo iniziare tutte le serie che non sono riuscita a vedere durante l'anno quindi
il 25 inizio vis a vis che me ne hanno parlato bene tutti quindi da guardare
il 27 inizio euphoria che il cortissimo quindi il 27 già l'avrò finita il 27
inizio you 2 perché esce la seconda serie quindi assolutamente da vedere in modo tale che poi il 29
inizio a vedere
rupaul allora amore con calma perché non ci sto capendo più niente ricapitolando 23 sera da zia concetta
24 mattina andiamo a ritirare ovviamente il panettone per poi portarlo il 24 sera dai tuoi perché il
25 a pranzo siamo dai miei e quindi no no 24 dei miei ma anche il 25
sempre tradizione si fa 24 cena ristretta dei parenti e poi 25 cena allargata e allora quella allargata
cambiamo a quella allargata non vengo
intima comunque vieni e anche allargata perché vengono apposta i parenti da caltanissetta quelli dalla calabria ma manco li conosco
e ma appunto é un'occasione per conoscersi non t'hanno mai vista però sentono sempre parlare di te
senti io devo stare con i miei
ma se li vedi sempre ogni settimana sei da loro
Ciao a tutti
buonasera buon natale maryna famiglia famiglia maryna molto piacere molto piacere maryna piacere
hai salutato nonna luisa? nonna luisa piacere ma c'eravamo già conosciute alla
cresima a
ali alice e clotilde
I cugini di caltanissetta quelli calabresi poi la famiglia di trieste che é di mio fratello esatto
e poi i nipotini alice maria e? beata elisabetta eli
Allora io mi sono permessa scusate di portare questo vino è un vino delle mie zone si prego
Perfetto allora famiglia
sbocciamo buon natale nonna mi sono messa la tuta così posso mangiare quanto voglio mi puoi fare esplodere
stasera poi pennichella sul divano e chi s'è visto s'è visto
di udine si quelli di novara okay posso sedermi? non mi sento molto bene
Ma dai teniamola cosí